so imagine you're wrapping up a night
out you're ready to head home but
driving is an an option and you don't
want to wait for public transit so you
use your phone and you fire up Ober or
lyft or whatever ride hailing app floats
or boat 20 minutes later you're faced
with this screen do you tip your driver
or not sometimes sometimes can't tell
you the last time I tipped it uber or
lyft sometimes I'll do it sometimes I
won't
I should tip a tip every single ride Wow
aren't we just like much better tipping
etiquette on ride-hailing apps is
totally unclear so riders are all over
the place with how they're tipping turns
out only about 35% of riders tip
consistently when I talk to drivers
tipping is definitely a big deal for
them it's something that's on their
minds and it can make or break a ride
for them this is Shireen Kothari I write
about tech and labor app based drivers
and cab drivers perform a very similar
service but riders in the u.s. pretty
consistently agree cab drivers should be
tipped I would never like walk out of a
cab without tipping the driver I
unsynced Lee tipped the cab driver so
what's going on here why is there so
much confusion around whether you should
tip on apps like uber or lyft
[Music]
this split between how riders tip cab
drivers versus app-based drivers can be
traced back to the origins of uber the
company that made smartphone ride
hailing a thing in the first place
uber definitely wasn't the first
ride-hailing app but it was the one
that's scaled the most quickly and
became a household name and those
quickly by 2015
uber accounted for over 90% of all app
base rides so ever set the standard in
terms of what's the right driver writer
courtesy and four years uber set the
standard that what's right is not
tipping your driver from the moment Eber
entered the market in 2009 there wasn't
even an option to tip in the app over
the next few years the company told
curious customers over twitter that a
20% tip was already built-in to the fair
and that there was no need for riders to
tip uber also told riders that its
drivers take home the majority of the
fare I thought that uber and lyft were
just like showering their drivers with
money so that you didn't have to tip
I've always thought that the tip was
built into the cost
boobers messaging around tipping had a
huge impact even as other ride hailing
apps during the market with tipping
built right into the app riders still
saw these services as something that
didn't require a tip still for a time
even though app based drivers weren't
making much in tips their pay was pretty
good and more importantly stable this
chart shows what app based drivers made
between 2012 and 2014 even though it
goes up and down
it basically hovers around $1500 a month
but that didn't last as the ride hailing
market got more crowded uber and its
competitors started to lower their fares
to stay competitive there's been many
reports that uber drivers pay has been
going down over the years we're saying
that as Commission is 25% but there are
some reports showing that it actually
may be as high as 40% and in some cases
there actually are like lowering the
rate that they give drivers per mile
after 2014 app based drivers pay dropped
dramatically and by 2018
drivers were making nearly half what
were making just six years before you
started to hear drivers get more and
more disgruntled if you saw this sort of
community form of drivers who felt like
these companies maybe ripping them off
or not giving them their fair share and
the lack of tip became a real problem
because the amount of money that uber
drivers were getting was comparable to
how much to be getting in a cab or most
people with tip to make matters worse
for drivers the reasons Boober had given
for not including tipping in its app
those turned out to be not entirely true
uber had said that tipping is included
in our bill that was sort of debunked
and actually some people ended up suing
uber over if not claiming part and they
ended up settling finally drivers
dissatisfaction reached a turning point
I love $27,000 because of you I bankrupt
because of you in 2017
Uber's then CEO Travis kalanick gets in
an uber and as he's leaving the driver
brings up driver pay - Travis you're
raising the standards and you drop in
the prices in general we have to be our
competitors
and Travis sort of starts to blame the
driver you know what what was sort of an
inflection point because it made the
company look like it didn't care about
its drivers and I think when you have
that hand-in-hand with this no tipping
policy it was not a good look for for
uber several months after this video
uber finally added a tipping option to
its app but that wasn't enough to change
the pervasive no tip culture the company
had already built I always tip cab
drivers but I don't always tip uber
drivers I didn't know if you go to
really I thought everyone's hit so
should you tip your uber driver well
that's still up to you but just keep in
mind just like cab drivers app based
drivers do not automatically get tipped
and if you tip in a cab you should
probably be doing the same for app based
rides reconsidering how we tip isn't
going to fix the larger problems with
the ride hailing industry but it's still
a good thing to do I will say that the
gig economy is tough it's a tough gig so
anything you can do to reward people for
good work I think is nice if you're
looking to past time on your next ride
share home I've got a great podcast
recommendation for you
it's called reset and I've got its host
Ariel here to tell you all about it hi
I'm Ariel Jim Ross and I'm the host of a
new tech news podcast called reset from
recode by Vox three times a week we're
going to take a deep look at the
technology that surrounds us and I mean
the weird and quirky stuff to the stuff
people often forget is tech like drugs
and the written word and anything that
you'd ever call an instrument reset
launches on October 15th and you can
subscribe right now by looking it up in
your favorite podcast app or by going to
Apple podcast com / reset